so Captain America gives up his shield
at the end of Avengers endgame but why
didn't he give it to Bucky Barnes
after all the Winter Soldier is the
perfect candidate for taking up the
mantle of Captain America there are
plenty of reasons why Steve Rogers chose
someone else instead major spoilers
ahead so consider yourself warned
at the end of Avengers endgame Captain
America returns to the Infinity stones
to their timelines to give himself the
life he was denied when he sacrificed
himself for the good of the world in
Captain America the First Avenger he
finds his way back to Peggy Carter and
then the Hulk sends him back in time
then we see Steve Rogers is an older man
with a wedding ring at his side is his
iconic red white and blue shield which
he passes on to his partner Sam Wilson
who humbly accepts it
of course this raises an important
question why did Captain America past
the shield to Sam Wilson and not Bucky
sure Sam Wilson was Captain America for
Time in the comic books but not until
years after the resurrected Bucky had
had his own time with the shield when
Bucky returned as a brainwashed killer
in 2014's Captain America the Winter
Soldier we rarely hear the character
speak but the recovering veteran had
plenty to say two years later in Captain
America Civil War I can't trust my own
mind if we can say nothing else
definitive about Bucky we know he's got
no illusions about who he is and what
he's done if anything he's harder on
himself than his old friend is while he
fights for his freedom against any and
all challengers he doesn't shy away from
his responsibilities and he doesn't hide
behind hydras brainwashing considering
all this it feels highly unlikely that
Bucky would accept the responsibility of
being Captain America or even take his
old friends shield as he and cap blew
off to Russia he confided I don't know
if I'm worth all the Steve
cap reminds Bucky that he wasn't in
control when he committed his crimes and
Bucky responds I know
but I did it Bucky wants a chance at
redemption but so far we haven't seen
him forgive himself
Bucky probably feels like wielding
Captain America's shield would be a bit
too much
even with his turn to good while we've
seen Bucky a couple of times since
Captain America's Civil War we never
learn a lot of information about it in
the Civil War mid-credits scene
he tells Steve he wants to be frozen
until he can be freed from hydras mental
conditioning otherwise another ambitious
criminal might transform him into an
unstoppable assassin okey who the hell
is Bucky in Black Panthers post-credit
scene we see him in Wakanda unfrozen and
being regarded by a bunch of children
who call him the white wolf and in
Avengers infinity war King T'Challa in
Ocoee a present a new arm to the former
assassin we know he's no longer frozen
and we know he has a new arm but that's
all we know we have no definitive word
about whether or not anyone has
succeeded in removing his Hydra
conditioning unless it can be proven
that Bucky's Hydra conditioning is gone
giving him cap shield is a dangerous
prospect giving somebody the symbolic
power of Captain America when that
person could turn into a murderer at any
given moment bad idea besides his
relationship with Steve Rogers we
haven't seen a lot of interaction
between Bucky and the other Avengers but
what we have seen hasn't been too
promising we've seen him come to blows
with cap Black Panther Black Widow and
Falcon to name just a few
The Avengers have since had the
opportunity to fight beside him in both
infinity war and endgame but not for any
extensive period of time if there's
still an Avengers team after endgame any
team member already knows two disturbing
things about Bucky 1 he's beaten up a
lot of their teammates and 2 he brutally
murdered Iron Man's parents knowing he
was a victim of Hydra and that Steve
Rogers vouches for him might win him
some trust with the team especially
since he fought on the right side in
infinity war an endgame but to be on the
team as the next Captain America that
doesn't seem like something the Avengers
would be down with does it if we assume
that someone could still activate
Bucky's Hydra conditioning than just
allowing him his freedom is a big risk
it's arguably a justifiable risk
considering his actions since Winter
Soldier but it's still a risk
without Captain America shield Bucky is
a deadly opponent his left arm gives him
super-strength and his new one is
presumably made of vibranium and even
without that strength he's proven
himself to be an expert hand-to-hand
combatant
he's a marksman he can operate any
weapon you put in front of him he can
fly just about anything and nine times
out of 10 brainwashed Bucky can lay low
any avenger standing in his way and an
aerodynamic shield made from the
strongest metal on earth and Bucky is
virtually unstoppable trusting Bucky
with his freedom is reasonable but
trusting him with that much power so
soon we think it's just too much to ask
don't agree well wanna fight about it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU or coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]